hello the Internet I'm gap I'm done with
the slow mo guys and we're here at
Purdue University in Indiana and I mean
I'm terrified of where we're still right
now quite intimidating you know you're
looking down well but barrel of a gun
this is slightly different
we're in front of a giant combustion
tube yeah well it's four is actually
testing flame acceleration and
deflagration to detonation transition
but what we're interested in is the
slimmer guys is blowing stuff up
so not really just like obliterate an
Islander what's the word you like ah
what's the matter eviscerate eviscerate
that's the one miss rates okay so we're
gonna eviscerate this Mack and circa
2004 something when did that I might
come out I don't know we've got some
retro equipment and we're basically
gonna put this over here very fast and
film it in slow motion and we're gonna
send it back to the 90s 28,000 frames a
second so how fast it go this is the
flame comes out about 1800 meters a
second so here we have our Mac speakers
and old-school like equipment you know
on a nice desk all from sort of late 90s
to early 2000 here it is the combustion
jr2 look at the state of all these tubes
I should just don't touch it oh don't
you dare I don't know what to do with
this thing so it always looks like it's
some sort of like film weapon whether
like oh it's new yeah like it's a James
Bond bad guy weapon salute man with the
Golden Gun and the max gone it's an
apple room yeah okay so uh we're gonna
film this at a thousand frames a second
in 4k on this bad boy and when that
inevitably isn't slow enough well cut to
this footage which is going to 28,000
500 frames a second the b25 11 cheers
Destin and now we've got a light that's
lighting it because pretty grisly day
oh I was like I didn't see anything in
real-time
he just heard like it went bang and then
the computer is suddenly over there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did not think it would be blue my table
my tailors room
I can't believe my tables room we see
how we have to use the computer now as
previously he had a keyboard and we
could use the computer right now I still
like it let's get this on Apple Mouse
obviously where's the rest of the
plastic bit oh it's some of it oh no the
plastic was just annihilated everywhere
look it's on the floor there some behind
the shoe it's just that we just be
shelled the Mac and then blasted the
screen face-first into this war no no
that's pretty much the only way to get
into a Mac we turned it into an I'm not
now lit it's the illusion of being right
so the keyboard is in didn't blow any of
the keys out didn't space well you
always lose the space based on time and
there's like the electronics of the
keyboard saw the press ease the press
e-tec what the metal in there the
squidgy ah yeah satisfying part oh these
feel great yeah yeah
speaker moist what I think my favorite
part of that is how just so quickly
there was just blue flame engulfing it
then there was orange flame and then Mac
hadn't even moved at this point yeah
don't even explosion was pretty much
done and the hack was maybe an inch from
start with the momentum to carry it all
the way to the wall
she's like a catapult this main quality
I'm even more scared of standing here
next this thing now I think we should
get one of these nice due to the
neighbors [ __ ] impress the girls with
that yeah look I'm like cannon huge
thanks to Purdue University in Indiana
for helping us make this video and
flying us out here to film with this
beast hopefully one day we can come back
and blow up some more stuff with it oh I
could think of plenty of things
everything
I got less yeah I'm making a list right
now yeah yeah yeah feel free to follow
us on Twitter subscribe to the slow mo
guys we've got a second channel I always
do that when I say second channel I just
assume I put the thing there right there
on you you're typing up talking up now
this has been like a good idea for like
a futuristic keyboard y'all think I
think that's a step backwards oh come on
it's satisfying with the but back to
physical buttons yeah but they're just
so much bad hopefully you enjoy that
we'll see you in the next one